[Musique]
il reconnaît que son français est limité
passé bonjour bonsoir
bonjour bonsoir je reconnais que je suis
un peu perdu 1 coquelin qui bombent le
torse
c'est pas trés êtes assez moqueur avec
nicolas sarkozy parce que le quinquennat
c'est lui
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme je les décris nicolas c'est
quelqu'un qui est constamment en
mouvement qui parlait constamment qui
aimait qu'on fasse attention à lui
cette énergie et ce charme lorsqu'il
était associé à un gala merkel moi qui
était une personne beaucoup plus sobre
réfléchi longtemps fait finit par
composer une bonne combinaison
contrairement aux apparences
l'actrice malika à la wii n'a pas joué
cette scène son visage a été incrustés
sur le corps d'une autre comédienne
une astuce utilisée par la production de
plus belle la vie pour pallier l'absence
de malika ici à droite qu'à contacter au
co vide est donc interdit de tournage
pour sept jours en chine d'où est partie
l'épidémie de covin 19 selon un rapport
gouvernemental publié par un quotidien
de hong kong
le premier cas est apparu le 17 novembre
mais nous sommes le 17 novembre ça veut
donc dire que le coronavirus à un an
berserk on peut fêter alors autant sur
la broche il mange un oignons crus et ne
se sent absolument rien naroff
avec la perte du goût et de l'odorat
certains internautes atteint du creux
vide n'ont pas résisté à l'envié de
partager cette étrange expérience en
mangeant de la sauce piquante
en croquant dans de l'ail ou en buvant
un verre de vinaigre dans la majorité
des cas goût et odorat reviennent après
quelques jours télé loisirs ils ont
demandé à leurs lecteurs avec quelle
personnalité il faudrait d'abord se
confiner pour se régaler et là c'est
philippe etchebest qui arrive en tête
devant cyril lignac
autre question avec quel journaliste se
confinait pour refaire le monde
et ben non c'est pas l'uia mars et jean
pierre pernaut anne claire coudray
ophélie meunier enfin avec un peu
confiné pour se marrer et là les
français voudraient se marrer avec alain
chabat pour une période de tellement bon
[Rires]
en belgique les autorités ont voulu être
rassurante de façon très sérieuse
c'était lors du point sur l'épidémie de
covin 19
regardez vous savez qu'au niveau du
gouvernement il y a eu une lettre qui a
donc autorisé saint nicolas à venir sans
quarantaine du grand nord où tout se
sait pas très bien où lé où ils se
cachent pour l'instant en faisant
exception pour le couvre feu ont claqué
me demander d'être prudent de rester à
distance ce qui au milieu de la nuit
n'est pas trop difficile
on lui a demandé de porter un masque
suffit axa bas ne va pas être forcément
tout à fait évident opération de com
identique en italie avec une autre
lettre celle d'un enfant de 5 ans qui
demandait au premier ministre de ne pas
confiné le père noël est bien là aussi
du cp comté a fait une longue réponse
sur facebook lé père noël m'a garanti
qu'il possède une attestation de
déplacement international jamais enfants
omnium marrant les embrasse bien sûr
parce que par exemple moi c'est interdit
mais non mais je suis frustré depuis
cette histoire de kobe dans depuis cette
histoire de colline dans le puits qui se
connaît jamais du coup nous et l'argent
qui passe sous les tables mais c'est
dans les comités miss france est allée
royce va lyrique de faire nommer un
désir qu quoi moi quand on parle de ça
me démange jeune fille de dix ans je
vais m'asseoir je suis un notable de la
région elle voudrait que oui je suis le
maire d'intel ont ça c'est grave mais
voilà la voile avant d'arriver au tuyau
web à ce qu'on ait compris donc quoi
c'est vrai c'est déjà arrivé ça ah oui
mais vous le saviez déjà des miss qui
vous ont dit on a pris un petit billet
pour on savait qu'on allait on allait on
allait passer de mobilité grave on
croyait que la femme était l'avenir de
l'homme pour le
mais dans le football c'est vrai on se
rend mieux compte finalement qu'elles
peuvent être que les hommes en politique
c'est pareil on était proche avec un mec
qui a donné des voitures c'est vrai
ch'ti ce nouveau nom en fait c'est le
papa de ma première dauchy alain garage
du coup et il prêté les voitures au
comité pour transporter les miss élues
tout ça mais du coup c'est cette
dauphine la cima qui va remplacer à la
régionale de santé grave je suis colère
là là vraiment je suis très colère çà me
sens du mig est une des façons de sortir
de l'impasse cinq fois que des conflits
que nous voyons non seulement aux états
unis mais aussi dans le monde occidental
dans le monde entier
c'est bon de pouvoir regarder l'autre
d'une manière qui reconnaissent son
humanité ses intérêts et ça nous ne le
faisons pas assez
c'est une épidémie aujourd'hui dans ce
pays les enfants restent assis
concentrer sur leurs études ils
oubliaient les dehors on laisse plus les
enfants être les enfants
[Applaudissements]
en cause l'utilisation excessive des
écrans ces derniers mois grandeur passée
son temps libre devant son téléphone
en deux ans il a pris plus de 10 kg et
souffre même d'hypertension nous sommes
devenus une culture beaucoup plus visuel
qui pensent en termes de spectacle de
bruit de conflits parce que ça fait
toujours de la bonne télévision alors
que soyons réalistes le débat l'empathie
l'écoutent ne sont pas toujours aussi
passionnant à la télévision qu' on
embrasse christine avant de partir mon
chien qui s'appelle comment maya bon on
n'est jamais déçu